our office was seven world trade center
on the 23rd floor so that's where i was
on the morning of september 11
2001. so if you think about it the first
plane
that hit the north tower flight 11
american airlines flight 11
uh flew over the roof of our building
our building was 47 stories it it
hit the tower in the 80s so flew right
over the roof of our building
hit the tower at the time i was
in the third floor mezzanine where our
breakfast area was so i was just having
some cheerios i did that every morning
and uh and i read the newspapers because
back then we didn't have smartphones
right so i was reading
the newspapers making sure i was up on
all the things that were happening
that day and the power went out in the
building
and this is a modern high-rise building
in new york city very unusual
for all the power to go out and then
five seconds later the power came back
on
and i knew because of my experience that
that mean we meant we lost a feeder
cable electrical feeder cable
and that our backup power had kicked in
this was in one of the two towers
this is in seven so it's directed at
seven world trade center there were
seven
buildings in the complex ours was number
seven it was directly across the street
from the north tower
got it okay uh and so i i didn't hear it
or anything i
all i knew was the power went out in the
building and
uh at the same time all these people who
were sitting at the glass
window facing the north tower uh
jumped up and screaming started running
to the exit
and i was like what's going on and i had
to grab one girl by the shoulders and
kind of shake her back to reality and
say what happened
and she said a plane hit the tower and
that's the first i
knew that that had happened and we had
had this happen before new york city it
was
a major thing but you know was not
something that had never happened before
planes have hit buildings in new york
city before that yeah yeah i mean if you
go back to world war ii
a b-52 bomber hit the uh empire state
building
oh [ __ ] yeah i had no idea so so and i
mean that was the biggest example but
there were examples of
people in small planes who maybe had a
heart attack or something
and flew into a high-rise building
i'm just saying that we had we had heard
of that before it wasn't something
completely unprecedented
so when i shook her and said
and she told me that the plane hit the
tower and i was like
okay game face going to work now
this is a big deal uh
you know the fire department the police
department they're all getting a
thousand
nine one one calls all at once right now
because everybody's reporting it
i don't have to do that but i have to
get ready to do my job
and my job was to go to the scene and
assist the incident commander as a
representative of the mayor with
anything he needed
in this case it would be the fire chief
and
uh anything he needed other than fire
department
he would turn to me or or my colleagues
in oem
and and say get me this get me that and
we would help him and we
would support we weren't the incident
commander because we weren't the experts
in that
uh but we were the ones that could help
him
carry things out smoothly right so i
went up to the 23rd floor to get my
radios
police radio fire radio oem radio
to ensure that our watch command which
is our listening and communicating hub
was doing a full activation a full
activation
means we have to contact 150 local state
federal and
private partner agencies to get them to
come into our emergency operations
center
our emergency operations center had 150
stations in it
for like state police for
communications verizon for
different people partners who could help
mitigate manage this emerging disaster
the um both of those were ready to go
both supervisors were on board
doing what we trained and trained and
trained and trained to do
my job was go to the scene so i went
down i went to my car on vc street
like an undercover police car kind of
thing i opened the trunk i took off my
tie and my dress shirt and i put on my
mayor's office jacket
with heavy leather boots and a stupid
green helmet they made us wear
to identify us
and they train us as firefighters that
you always
look try to look at three sides of a
building that's being compromised
before you go in it so you have a good
size up in your head
so that's what i wanted to do in order
to do that i had to go from the street
level
up an outdoor concrete staircase to the
plaza level which is one story up
the world trade center plaza and and i
went between one world trade center and
six world trade center
which was next door and i went out and i
saw the plaza
and if people can remember that
there was a big sphere there it was the
world trade center
so there's a big sphere a golden sphere
of the world there
and i remember seeing that and around
that on the plaza
was debris and
fire and black smoke
and things pieces of the building
crashing to the ground
and the paper all the paperwork from the
offices was fluttering down
amid the smoke and that's when i
kind of said in my head this is maybe
more than a little plane
because you had no idea what kind of
plane it was no
i mean we we just kind of i guess
everybody just kind of assumed it was an
errant
uh private aircraft yeah exactly the guy
had a heart attack he flew into a tower
right
at that level i went into the north
tower which was the first one to be hit
to go to the fire command station which
was in the lobby at the street level
in order to go down from the plaza level
to the street level there was an
interior escalator
and there were hundreds of office
workers uh like a funnel
trying to get onto that escalator to go
down so that they could get out of the
building
and i noticed in that moment what they
were not doing
they were not pushing and screaming and
kicking and trampling each other
in fact these regular office workers
for everyone who was obese or pregnant
or injured
or disabled if anyone had that
problem there were four or five office
workers
helping that person so it was the
opposite of panic
it was something that i was very proud
of
that humanity is good in general
even with this evil that was unfolding
in front of our eyes
people were helping each other in in
that's the truth
of humanity that by far
people want to love and help each other
i got into that i got into that funnel
of people
and started going down the escalator and
as you
came down the escalator to the ground
level the street level
lobby you look out and there were
hundreds of firemen
in their turnout gear with the yellow
stripes
awaiting their assignment to go up
and i laughed inside my head
because i completely understood why the
cops called us bumblebees
because when we get together in the
hundreds like this it looks like a hive
when you're kind of watching it from
afar yeah and that's exactly what it
looked like
it looked like a hive of bees except
these were firefighters
awaiting their assignment to go up the
stairs
i